how's it going everybody Maxwell McGee
here and today we're taking a look at
trove and to help me do that I'd run by
Andrew from Trion Worlds Andrew thanks
for sitting down on the couch with him
absolutely oh so tell me I have a very
limited idea of what trove is once you
go and set up big picture what is this
so this is a cubic voxel game oh it's an
alpha
so trying worlds were an MMO studio we
saw like what a lot of other boxful
games were doing and we thought hey
let's you know see what we do take what
we do well
so take cubic voxels put it online ad
you know adventure exploration things
like classes leveling up collecting
equipment do all that stuff and then
throw you a bunch of players in playing
it together and then really bring in the
community as well so we saw a lot of
opportunity to not only let you make
really simple things like weapons but
all sorts of stuff customize your
character and all sorts of ways put
assets in the game that other players
also get to use so this is where you
start the game you go in your home world
so this is your home world
okay every player has a home world which
is your personal space to build other
people can come visit you you we are an
online game so pretty much anyone else
who plays the game can stop by if you're
friends with them they can just jump
straight to you through that otherwise
you can create a portal for other
players to get to you through okay yeah
and you can give people other other
people permission as well so if you want
someone else to come help you you know
build with you work with you on your
home world you can also do that and if
it turns out that was a mistake you
regret that decision mound or something
you can remove those permissions as well
so what the core mechanics is you can
stroke okay and you can flex like your
basis from the world you have course so
you know being cubic voxel that's that's
the thing you redo especially since it's
your home world again other people's
home worlds you can't I don't say we
sort of gone transparent here so that
players can see through and see exactly
what they're mining out what you're what
you're building what you're mining all
that stuff and then you hit tab okay and
you jump back to adventure mode and
adventure mode you can as you saw
earlier I could you know can hack and
slash kill the barely any bugs you have
smashed so I'm playing one of our
classes we have two classes right now
this look at night he has a smash he
also has a shield okay and then he has
charge and this guy's our gun slinger so
he has a different set of what
to shoot he also Holly guns grafted to
his hands yes yes and so as I mentioned
earlier our community actually makes a
lot of our game at this point so they
put in it's like modding so you know
things you make go in the game for
everyone um so we have a community
creation process where you submit at
other people offer feedback so we have
different weapons that like these eye
ball guns that someone's made for us
we've got yeah the tommy guns you saw
all sorts of stuff and then i imagine
there's some sort of community voting of
vote down vote trust and Bruce yeah
totally so this just call me makes penis
guns don't let his penis guns into the
game yeah there is some gates like that
your creativity can be unleashed but
maybe not you know everything you might
want to make sure sure um let me also
have other things actually
so like this hairstyle was actually made
by a community member um but then we
also have masks and hats can also be
made these also give staff these are
equipment slots that you can get as
drops in the world okay yeah I see it
there we got a lot of green around oh
yeah and then if you get some loot that
you really like we actually of a forging
system which lets you change the stats
around all kind of reroll them so you
can build the equipment set that you
really want to have so if I really want
to you know this mask and the witch hat
and these snake guns why not why not
that I can I can make them have like if
I want to pack speed or damage or
anything I can make them have those
stats um so this is a adventure world
and basically it would it would put you
in this world with other players um
based on the difficulty level you chose
and so again we're very very PvE
oriented game so all the loot drops for
each individual person all the
experience it's not even split everyone
gets our own version of experience this
is our rainbow tree and what what means
is basically that each of these pieces
can either appear or not appear or
appear in a different place each time
you do it so okay so the community it
sounds like the community is sort of
building like these building blocks for
a dungeon yeah game grabs in the stick
Simone again exactly configuration yeah
exactly exactly
um which is really cool there's all
sorts of variations so you can make
things that are like castles where the
rooms go inside the structure you can
make one like this where it's a tree
that has different appendages coming off
of it mm-hmm
and it's also procedural so you know the
rules will be different for each one
that gets generated so some of these are
jumping puzzles some of these are just
you know a stair where you can take up
it's always different so one of the
changes we made
with community feedback is to actually
make the hats and the masks of dropped
items that have stats before we were
thinking oh we'll sell you know it's
cosmetic it's a thing we have just
really comes many free-to-play right but
then we realized we don't make the best
stuff frankly you know and we can spend
a lot of time on something like we can
make a really cool amount and we'll keep
doing that but in terms of hats and face
I was like why don't we just open this
up we're going to stop selling it we're
gonna put it in the game and we did that
we made that change it's just been
beneficial awesome Andrew working folks
go if they want to if they want to learn
more about the game or sign up for it I
like it so yeah so trove game.com I'm
learning about the game we have a
support program there which as I said is
basically a pre-order system for a
free-to-play game okay so you get your
dollars worth in terms of in-game
credits and then what's gonna happens
we're gonna go to beta we're going to
wipe pretty much everything and we're
going to return those credits to you
along with some extra okay so it's even
beneficial to support McDavid alpha if
you don't want to we do two giveaways we
have a reddit you know our trove and we
do giveaways there sometimes streamers
do giveaways and if you make something
for the game you also get game access so
if you want to make something that's
another way to play the game awesome
well thank you so much for come by and
showing off again yep absolutely